the Joe Rogan experience you haven't
gotten out of attacking that
satisfaction no there's no that Keith
Richards nobody went to sleep
really he had this sound activated
recorder that he got by the side of the
bed and and his guitar and he went to
sleep one night woke up the next morning
there on the tape recorder oh there was
some voice activation in the night he
played it it was satisfaction my friend
Matt yep
no I haven't had that yeah my friend
works at a school in Connecticut where
his kids go or Keith Richards kids go
mhm and Keith Richards will ride on a
bike to school with a [ __ ] bandana on
and like my friends like holy [ __ ]
that's Keith Richards like he's just
kind of hanging around with normal
people and he said it freaks you out
when you see him you're like what that's
[ __ ] Keith Richards he just hangs out
just like you know he's a giant
superstar but he drifts into the real
world
and it just freaks people out yeah it's
it's it's it's I mean I only met Keith
Richards in groups of people
evany that were what's really like
bicycling into you yeah but still it's
so it's so amazing surreal so surreal
he's an epic human yeah yes the voice
recordings new that's why I haven't had
any new it's a new idea that I have
because there's times that I did this
solution to this team thing and the and
the separation of America and giving
more polarized that's gonna be solved by
Joe and the tank at some point we can
count on that know now that you got the
recording we're gonna solve it ourselves
I think we're gonna solve it ourselves
through just time I think as we're
getting back to Pinker we're talking
about Pinker earlier that he gets so
much [ __ ] for saying that things are
better now than ever
it doesn't dismiss horrific acts of
techno a soar terrible thing and it
doesn't say that the battle is over
right now I mean this is one of the
things that I would push in my little
microcosm push for so hard in Penn &
Teller
you know teller and I would have real
trouble just crossing a finish line I
would just say to him you know tell her
we've done five seasons of [ __ ] and
it went well let's go out the two of us
have coffee and doughnuts
and let's just say wow we did that and
then push ahead for the next thing and I
would just I just think that Pinker is
like that with me Pinker's like saying
you know human beings we're doing okay
we're doing okay we've done some really
good things now let's get back to work
[Applause]